Мені постійно чулося, коли я на вулиці ходив, що мама мене гукала.
Я обертався. Думав, може вона прийшла до мене.
У розмові з 13-річним Сашком найчастіше звучить
єдине слово - "мама".
Саме відсутність матері поруч ось уже майже два роки
змусила хлопця вже не відчувати себе дитиною, як він каже сам.
Після примусової депортації і фактично полону у так званій "ДНР",
він змушений шукати власну маму, з якою його після оточення Маріуполя
розлучили російські окупанти.
Я з нею не бачився з 15 квітня 2022 року.
Вона потрапила в полон.
За стільки часу я нічого про неї не чув.
Регулярно хлопець переглядає останні світлини з мамою,
які збереглися в соцмережах.
На них Сніжана Козлова разом з чоловіком і двома дітьми -
старшим сином Олександром та донькою Вікторією -
зустрічає родинні свята і гуляє Маріуполем.
Саме там родина застала повномасштабне вторгнення
Росії в Україну. Вітчим хлопця пішов на фронт,
а мама з ним і сестрою мала виїхати до бабусі - на Чернігівщину.
Вона мені подзвонила 24 лютого.
"Мамо, що мені робити?" Я їй кажу: "Куди люди, туди й ти".
Людей вивозять і я не знаю, де вони сиділи.
Я думала, може, їх вивозять десь.
Виїжджати не вийшло.
Так ми думали пересидіти і тоді виїхати.
Вже було чутно і вибухи.
Ну, і там ми перебували, у нас було мало їжі, ми економити намагалися.
Ми в підвалі нашого будинку ховалися.
Все змінилось 24 березня.
Тоді був обстріл сильний.
І я в той момент був на подвір'ї, біля мангала.
Я побіг, боявся за сестричку, побіг на другий поверх.
Тільки добігаю, і тут вибух.
Міна на мій будинок впала.
У мене в оці почало дуже пекти.
Уламок від снаряда серйозно уразив око хлопця.
Єдиними лікарями, які залишалися у місті, були військові медики.
До них, не взявши документів і лишивши меншу дитину у батьків чоловіка,
Сніжана повезла сина в укриття в заводі імені Ілліча.
На той час там перебували сотні українських захисників,
зокрема підрозділи 36-ї окремої бригади морської піхоти ЗСУ.
Це був бункер, там був військовий шпиталь.
Там постійно обстрілювали і світло зникало.
Я хотів мультики завантажити.
Останню гру свою видалив. І не вистачило пам'яті на телефоні.
Це був капець! Не було інтернету.
Я там познайомився з одним дядьком, його звати Геною,
позивний "Хан". Я йому допомагав лікувати його.
12 квітня 2022 року завод був повністю оточений російськими солдатами.
З усіма українськими захисниками здатися в полон РФ
довелося і Саші та його мамі. У фільтраційному таборі
у селі Безіменне поблизу Маріуполя Сніжану допитували по кілька годин.
А по її сина того ж дня приїхала пара невідомих:
вони не дали йому попрощатися з мамою і забрали в донецьку лікарню на "лікування".
Втім, жодної допомоги хлопцю не надали,
натомість пізніше пообіцяли відправити до дитбудинку в Росії.
Я думав, що це так жартують, що нас разом заберуть кудись.
Я думав, що її повернуть дуже швидко.
Мені було дуже страшно без мами.
Сенс їм, в чому їм вигода, вигода навіть?
Якби там зробили операцію в Донецьку, то я б міг ще щось бачити.
А зараз уже дуже погано бачу цим оком.
Кудись в якийсь там табір хотіли мене повезти, але я відмовився.
Я думав, що краще я буду сидіти там в лікарні, і чекатиму бабусю.
Одного дня хлопцеві вдалося вийти на зв’язок з бабусею,
хоч йому і не дозволяли дзвонити. Телефон дала
одна з місцевих пацієнток лікарні.
Душа чує, що рідна дитина десь мене шукає насправді.
Мені Саша дзвонить, каже: "Бабусю, без тебе мене не забере ніхто.
Треба тільки тобі їхати". А мати, мати, кажу, де? Каже: "Не знаю".
Я кажу: "Давай мені соціальну службу, яка там має до тебе підійти.
Давай мені лікарів, давай мені адресу, де ти знаходишся".
І все, я листок і ручка, і пишу.
Жінка вирушила до окупованого Донецька по онука.
Написати чи подзвонити бабусі ще раз йому не дозволили.
Врешті через балтійські країни та територію Росії
Людмила змогла дістатися так званої "ДНР".
Там у травні 2022-го відбулася її зустріч з хлопчиком.
Одразу після цього вони вирушили додому назад - через Росію.
По приїзду на Чернігівщину жінка з онуком взялися
разом шукати маму хлопчика.
Спершу фото Сніжани публікували у онлайн-групах родичів зниклих безвісти українців,
потім - писали десятки листів у Міжнародне інформаційне бюро
та до президента України з проханням допомогти з пошуком.
Минулого року Олександр Радчук їздив до швейцарського Давоса
на Міжнародний економічний форум, де просив польського президента Анджея Дуду
та британського прем’єр-міністра Бориса Джонсона
вплинути на міжнародну спільноту, аби почати розшук мами в Росії.
В кінці лютого я ще поїду в Америку.
Моя основна мета - довести країнам іншим, що Росія - агресор,
щоб вони мені допомогли мою маму звільнити з полону.
Я думаю, вона десь є, ну вона десь жива.
Дитино моя, як мені, нам тебе не вистачає.
Знайдися, відгукнися, хоч відгукнися, де ти!
Чекаємо все-таки, чекаємо.
Сашко і його бабуся роблять чергову спробу дізнатися, де мама.
Вони їдуть до Києва на зустріч із керівником волонтерських груп
пошуку зниклих українців - Олегом Котенком.
Торік - Уповноваженого з питань зниклих безвісти осіб.
Олег Котенко припускає, що найбільш вірогідне місцеперебування
Сніжани Козлової - це тюрма для військовополонених у Таганрозі,
куди відвезли інших встановлених полонених з Маріуполя.
Те, що малого повернули, це уже щастя.
Її рахують військовою.
Але рано чи пізно вони розберуться. Я знаю, це 501 батальйон 36 бригади.
Вони були на Ілліча. Вони дійсно з пораненими.
Я не знав, що там таке відбулося. Я вперше почув про те,
що там були ще й цивільні. Україна веде перемовини
через міжнародні організації, але на цьому потрібно наголошувати.
Щоб офіційно подати запит на інформацію про маму Сашка
у "Червоний Хрест", а ті - в Росію, волонтери допомагають хлопчику
і його бабусі правильно оформити документи.
На розшук за цими даними можуть піти тижні і місяці.
За той час хлопець готується далі боротися за власний зір
після поранення і зробити операцію на оці у київській лікарні.
Я хочу стати пожежником.
Ось закінчу школу, потім поїду вчитися.
Щоб допомагати іншим людям.
Щоб коли, якщо вони будуть у біді, щоб їм допомогти.
Хлопець зізнається DW: дає інтерв’ю з думкою про те,
що є хоча б найменший шанс, що в мережі це відео побачить і його мама.